[Musica]
qui ma in quello che abbiamo appena
visto c'è veramente il cuore
permettetemi di dire questo comunque se
il tema del teteks il tema conduttore di
te dex padova è la rinascita non trovo
modo migliore per cominciare il mio talk
facendomi sentire il pianto di un
neonato
intanto della nato il grande respiro che
ognuno di noi quando viene al mondo deve
fare per vivere per passare dal mondo
acqueo del grembo materno al mondo aereo
del nostro pianeta e questo grande
respiro e importante ed è un atto dovuto
se vogliamo continuare questo viaggio
meraviglioso nella vita questo è mike
maric mike mari ci ha scritto un libro
la scienza del respiro e ho preso a
prestito dalle una sua definizione noi
siamo come respiriamo ovvero il modo in
cui lo respiriamo è la spia del nostro
benessere psichico e fisico infatti la
mancanza di respiro e il primo sintomo
dei pazienti affetti da scompenso
cardiaco e se lo scompenso cardiaco e
terminale se uno scompenso cardio è
avanzato questa mancanza di respiro può
essere drammatica prima avete
sperimentato cosa vuol dire non vedere
immaginate cosa vuol dire respirare male
o respirare pochissimo
la migliore è esposta terapeutica per
questi pazienti è il trapianto di cuore
non solo in termini di sopravvivenza
perché a dieci anni dal trapianto il 50
per cento dei pazienti adulti e il 65
per cento dei pazienti pediatrici sono
ancora vivi sono pazienti che hanno meno
di un anno di attesa di vita quando
vengono inseriti in lista d'attesa per
il trapianto
quindi il trapianto di cuore la miglior
risposta terapeutico non solo per la
gara sopravvivenza che garantisce ma
soprattutto per la qualità di vita
perché ogni paziente nel momento in cui
gli garantiamo la sopravvivenza ci
chiederà subito un altra cosa
una vita di qualità e dopo il trapianto
cardiaco più del 90 per cento dei
pazienti possono tornare a lavorare o
avere una vita di relazione
efficace e soddisfacente bene allora il
trapianto di cuore per questi pacchetti
è sostanzialmente una rinascita e
potremmo dire che la capacità di
riprendere a respirare bene è
sostanzialmente assimilabile a quel
vagito quel pianto del neonato che si
affaccia la vita però non ci sono
abbastanza cuori non perché non ci siano
donatori l'italia primi posti in europa
per donatori per milione di abitanti non
ci sono cuori perché fortunatamente una
legge dello stato seriamente applicata
non come in questa diapositiva e cioè
l'obbligatorietà di indossare il casco
sui ciclomotori per i ragazzi ha fatto
sì che le morti cerebrali post
traumatiche siano fortunatamente sparite
azzerate pensate che in 35 anni da
quando vincenzo gallucci eseguito
proprio qui a padova il primo trapianto
di cuore ad oggi l'età media del
montorio è passata da poco meno di 18
anni
a poco più di 65 anni e se questo non
impatta sfavorevolmente organi quali i
reni il fegato il polmone
sfortunatamente impatta negativamente il
cuore e allora l'evoluzione tecnologica
la ricerca ha cercato di trovare dei
surrogati al trapianto di cuore
sviluppando i vad che sono dei
ventricoli artificiali cioè delle
piccole pompe che vanno a sostituire la
funzione del ventricolo sinistro quando
un solo ventricolo il sinistro più
importante è ammalato ma quando entrambi
i ventricoli destro e sinistro sono
disfunzionamenti l'unica risposta
terapeutica resta l'impianto di un cuore
artificiale totale questo è l'unico
cuore artificiale totale attualmente
disponibile si chiama syncardia è stato
sviluppato dopo la seconda guerra
mondiale molto semplice e forse la sua
semplicità giustifica il fatto che noi
stiamo ancora utilizzato perché i
sistemi semplici garantiscono in fondo
risultati sicuri solo due voci di
poliuretano con all'interno una membrana
di poliuretano che viene movimentata
dall aria compressa pompata da un
compressore all'interno del ventricolo
artificiale attraverso quei tubicini che
escono dal torace del paziente
bene questo è un paziente con un
ventricolo artificiale ventricoli
artificiali garantiscono un'adeguata
qualità di vita
sono piccoli silenziosi perché sono
elettrici ma non garantiscono la stessa
sopravvivenza di un trapianto di cuore
ben diverso è un cuore artificiale
totale perché garantisce sicuramente la
sopravvivenza ma non garantisce
un'adeguata qualità di vita perché
richiede una terapia anticoagulante
molto spinta ma soprattutto è
estremamente estremamente rumoroso spero
che questo è il rumore
il quale deve convivere un paziente
impiantato con un cuore artificiale
totale quindi può essere inteso
solamente come ponte al trapianto cioè
possiamo vivere con quel cuore
artificiale totale in attesa che arrivi
un cuore ma se non ci sono fuori la
situazione capite anche voi che diventa
drammatica bene quel cuore artificiale è
stato impiantato è stato detto prima per
la prima volta in italia padova nel 2007
e quel paziente che è stato impiantato
con quel cuore artificiale ha vissuto
quattro anni con un cuore artificiale
totale
prima di essere sottoposto al trapianto
a tutt'oggi ancora i pazienti che ha
vissuto più a lungo al mondo con un
cuore artificiale totale
prima di essere trapiantato il 9
settembre del 2011 quattro anni dopo
bene col cuore artificiale impiantato
per quattro anni e questo avete la
possibilità di vederlo ma se siete molto
curiosi potete andarlo a vedere a trento
perché esposto al museo e al museo della
scelta dopo questa premessa
assolutamente necessaria per farvi
capire tutte le problematiche connesse
al problema della sostituzione del cuore
entriamo nel vivo nel vivo della
presentazione parlando di coraggio e
innovazione perché il coraggio e
innovazione sono i pilastri fondanti del
nostro gruppo di ricerca che all'interno
di un progetto ancora più ampio che si
chiama life lab se preferite opifici un
vite cerca di dare una risposta a questo
problema con due progetti un primo
progetto è quello di creare un cuore
artificiale totale che abbia
caratteristiche diverse
cioè sia più piccolo rispetto a quello
che vi ho fatto vedere quindi posso
essere impiantato in pazienti adulti
uomini e donne in adolescenti quindi con
superficie corporea più piccole ma
soprattutto che abbia una miglior
biocompatibilità che quindi non
necessiti di questa terapia
anticoagulante antiaggregante con tutte
le complicanze che questo comporta e
soprattutto soprattutto sia silenzioso
la seconda ipotesi di ricerca è quella
di produrre un cuore bionico partendo da
un cuore di maiale dal quale rimuoviamo
tutte le cellule in questo cuore voi non
vedete in cardiomiociti una cellula
endoteliale una cellula muscolare liscia
però riconoscete ancora l'albero
coronarico vedete quella specie di
autostrade
quali sono le coronarie potremo fare
anche una coronarografia c'è solamente
collagene
e poi ripopolare quel cuore con le ips
del potenziale ricevente le ps sono
delle cellule staminali particolari che
potrebbero differenziarsi trasformarsi
nelle cellule che solitamente abitano il
cuore bene voi vi domanderete dove siamo
e cosa ci manca
cosa ci manca proveniva critico per la
ricerca di tagli ai finanziamenti per
cui il momento in cui potremo avere i
finanziamenti adeguati con la tenacia la
perseveranza del nostro gruppo di
ricerca sicuramente potremmo scrivere
una pagina diversa una pagina nuova per
quei pazienti con lo scompenso cardiaco
in fase terminale
una pagina di rinascita e adesso prima
di concludere questo talk vorrei che voi
leggete questa poesia che si intitola
cuore artificiale
potete leggerla mentre scorre alle mie
spalle è stata scritta da michele
bellucci michele bellucci si è spento
per una neoplasia è un paziente che ha
vissuto due volte il concetto di
rinascita l'esperienza di rinascita il
tema della rinascita per chi ha 12 anni
e stato sottoposto a un trapianto di
cuore e ha 24 anni è stato sottoposto
all impianto di un cuore artificiale
totale e quindi chi meglio di michele
bellucci scrivendo queste parole
scrivendo questa poesia può dirci cosa
vuol dire vivere il tema della rinascita
il tema della rinascita che chiunque di
noi chiunque in questa sia la vorrebbe
restituire alla propria madre e come
fare per restituire il tema della
rinascita la propria madre perdermi un
punto di vista in maniera abbastanza
semplice prendendola in braccio come lei
ci prendeva in braccio quando eravamo
neonati
grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]